merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre Naël 17 ans est mort
abattu par un policier qu'un jour plutôt
à lucen Camara décédé dans les mêmes
circonstances depuis ces événements
atroces vous n'avez posé aucun acte
politique pour répondre aux problèmes
qui se dressent face à nous comment un
jeune de 17 ans peut-il être tué par un
policier en République française
pourquoi 16 personnes ont-elles trouvé
la mort depuis un an et demi en France
pour refus d'obtempérer quand
l'Allemagne n'en compte qu'à mort en
disant et le plus glaçant combien de
Naëlle n'ont pas été filmées à présent
pour justifier l'inaction vous versez
dans le déni vous m'avez dit hier les
émeutes que connaît le pays n'ont rien à
voir avec la mort de Naël pire vous
voulez faire peser sur nous la
responsabilité de la colère quand elle
prend racine dans un meurtre audio
madame la Première ministre ni les
interpellations ni la répression
deviendront tarir la soif de justice de
la jeunesse seule une réponse politique
et de nature à apaiser durablement le
pays le retour au calme ne se décrète
pas il se construit
lorsqu’alliance police est l'une ça
parle d'entrée en guerre contre des
nuisibles il ne parle plus la langue de
la République voici ce qui devrait
interpeller fortement votre gouvernement
et les relais d'opinion dans ce pays
regardez la situation en face madame la
Première ministre il faut un débat à
l'Assemblée nationale quand
prendrez-vous au sérieux les
propositions que nous vous faisons
êtes-vous oui ou non favorable à
l'abrogation du permis de tuer de la loi
Cazeneuve qui a provoqué l'explosion du
nombre de morts en cas de refus
d'obtempérer allez-vous oui ou non créer
un comité vérité et justice pour faire
toute la transparence sur les cas de
violence policière allez-vous oui ou non
créez un fond d'indemnisation pour les
commerçants et collectivités victimes
des événements de cette semaine
comptez-vous enfin dépayser les affaires
de violence policière et allonger la
formation des policiers madame la
Première ministre cet ordre établi n'est
plus tenable
la parole
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît madame
la Première ministre vous avez la parole
madame le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente
comme vous comme de nombreux Français
j'ai été ému et choqué par la mort d'un
jeune de 17 ans la semaine dernière à
Nanterre je l'ai d'ailleurs dit au Sénat
très clairement dès mercredi dernier le
gouvernement a fait preuve de la plus
grande transparence dans cette affaire
et la justice établira toute la vérité
mais madame la Présidente panneau dans
un moment comme celui que nous
traversons oui nous devons regarder la
réalité en face
car depuis une semaine face aux
violences qui ont éclaté je cherche vos
condamnations et j'entends des excuses
avec votre partie vous instrumentalisez
un drame vous refusez de condamner
clairement les violences vous refusez
d'appeler au calme alors que nos
policiers et nos gendarmes luttent pour
préserver l'ordre républicain alors que
des sapeurs-pompiers combattent des
incendies alors que des mères sont aux
côtés des habitants et sont la cible de
violence des mairies et des écoles sont
incendiées des magasins pillés des élus
et leurs familles attaquées et vous vous
cherchez des coupables partout dans
toutes nos institutions républicaines
sauf chez les auteurs de violence
alors vous auriez pu comme vos alliés de
la nupesse exprimez votre émotion à la
suite du décès d'un jeune de 17 ans
demandé justice et appeler sans
ambiguïté au retour au calme mais vous
et les autres parlementaires insoumis
vous avez choisi un autre chemin celui
de l'outrans celui de la brutalité
verbale celui de l'excuse constante de
la violence
alors madame la Présidente panneau quand
vos députés rejettent tout appels au
calme vous sortez du champ républicain
quand une de vos députés affirme que la
fin justifie les moyens vous sortez du
champ républicain
contre votre leader parle de permis de
tuer pour les policiers de peine de mort
pour les jeunes des quartiers et nous
traitent de chiens de garde vous sortez
du champ républicain
les violences madame la Présidente pano
rien ne peut les excuser et pendant que
vous jetez de l'huile sur le feu pendant
que vous donnez des excuses au
délinquants nous nous sommes engagés
pour rétablir l'ordre républicain et la
justice ne vient jamais de la violence
je vous remercie merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup madame